Working within a game engine brings its own unique set of ways to approach it.
So we're going to go over those right now.
So animating within a game engine, you have different types of animations within it.
So depending on how you wish to approach or how you wish to get that animation,
we want to familiarize you with those.
Now one is called an input animation.
Now this is typically where you want to take a controller and to control the character.
So this is typically more for your real time or for your gaming type of things or even a user input scenario.
Automotives can use it to have a customer play around with certain things so they may have an iPad
or some other form of input control that's going to control these characters or control the changes done via an input.
So those animations are then controlled in real time.
Now the next one is called the linear animation.
Now you'll be bringing in your animation, and this is pretty typical for movie animations and so forth,
where you're bringing in that file via an FBX or some other pre-recorded mocap animation typically.
You can also bring in Olympic, which is for raw data frame by frame caches,
and that's more for changes in the vertices.
And so that would be more like your cloth effects and so forth like that would be brought in.
Then you'd apply it into Sequencer.
Now using a control rig, you can keyframe directly in Sequencer or even use animation and adapt it even further.
Now the third one is Live Link.
Now you may have heard of this. This is how you can use, which is a plug-in,
either through a mocap suit, Maya, or some other 3D application, and you drive the animation live.
So what you'd be capturing you would be seeing that.
So you can then use Take Recorder to input the animation, record it directly within Sequencer,
playing over the top, even layering your animations.
So this is a very useful way of bringing in your animations.
Now we want to discuss something else that's called root motion.
So this is just yet another form of your input animation.
So we have it as in-place or game-driven motion.
Now these are great like it states for input.
These animations are in place, but they don't go anywhere.
So the Animation Blueprint will use this to push it around within the capsule so your root bone doesn't move.
Now the problem you can see above is the root motion not activated or extracted into the capsule.
You'll see the character on the right, he jumps outside of the capsule and then snaps back.
Obviously, you would not want that for your typical animations.
Now animation-driven that goes someplace or root motion is intended for Sequencer to drive it.
So you are going to be moving that capsule, moving the root motion as you can see on the left.
So that way it doesn't snap back into place.
Now there is an enable root motion option that will force the capsule to move according to that root motion.
Gets a little confusing, but as you work with it more and more, you will become more familiarized where it works.